overwatch is a game about choosing the  best characters for the situation and  switching when necessary but some heroes  just don't get as much playtime I'm Tony  and this is your symmetrical gamespot  news update according to game director  Jeff Kaplan symetra is one of the least  played heroes because of her situational  usefulness apparently many players will  switch to a different character once  they've lost the first control point  Blizzard is aware of this situational  nature and is currently tweaking the  character Kaplan hasn't evolved any  details but he did say the new and  improved symetra could be in the works  by November if you're waiting to try out  the new symetra there's still plenty of  content to experience in the game right  now the first new map is live a new hero  reveal is on the horizon and other  character tweaks can be experienced  first in blizzards public test realm to  keep up with all the latest overwatch  news you're already in the right place  you